I told you earlier in the show that
America Fest held an event over the
weekend and it was horrible and
dystopian and we are going to look at a
few clips and really it reminds me these
people are dangerous but they also are
way better than the left at organizing
these sort of pump-up events I'm going
to start with a clip of Donald Trump Jr
coming out and I know that it's going to
be you know it's funny it's cartoonish
it's like a wrestling intro it's also a
little loud just as a heads up if you're
listening in headphones but I'm turning
it down for us but make fun of this at
your own Peril because this type of
stuff works here's Donald J Trump Jr
coming out
[Applause]
[Music]
a pyrotechnics if you're only listening
[Music]
boy yeah I mean listen I'm with you that
it is hard not to laugh because it's so
absurd but I've spoken so many times
before the right knows how to throw
these events coalesce people they do
multiple C packs Turning Point USA does
events they've got America Fest as one
of them they've got the Turning Point
Summit all these different things this
stuff actually does get people engaged
and part of the reason that the youngest
voting group 18 to whatever
isn't even more left skewed is that the
right does a way better job of
activating and getting people together
and the pyrotechnics and the music and
the entire thing the left doesn't have
it the closest thing we had at one point
was net net Roots nation which I used to
go to but no longer do it's very milk
toast it's very mediocre a lot of
infighting a lot of like uh you know all
the people that actually have success
that should be leading sessions we have
political disagreements with them so
we're gonna have like it's it's a mess
it's a mess the right is actually better
at this So eventually Don Jr spoke and
again he continues to be obsessed like
many of these people obsessed with
gender today pushing for three-year-old
children to be indoctrinated by their
purple hair teachers
to go through changing permanent sexual
reassignment surgeries and if parents
and by the way the little skips these
are in the source videos I unfortunately
can't do anything about them Aaron
parents want to maybe be a part of that
conversation let's be clear that kid
can't buy a pack of cigarettes for
another 15 years
it can't vote although hunt them too
because of course they don't know what
they're talking about
for another 15 years but they can and we
don't know what Junior is talking about
either and I may not know for another 15
years they decide to mutilate their
bodies permanently
to satisfy
some insane woke teacher satisfy what is
the deal with that okay
um obsessed obsessed with gender
obsessed with imaginary things that
aren't actually happening and the gender
Obsession continued Republican senator
Josh Hawley a sort of pseudo
insurrectionist that was the way I would
refer to him he came out and he said
here's an idea boys turn off the porn
and go talk to a real woman you can give
your self too and pour yourself out to
young men pour yourself out into a woman
make on a date right how about it
young man why don't you
America Fest quickly turning into like a
pickup artist type conference instead of
a right-wing political conference I
guess with this pseudo-in-cell group
it's the same thing but Dad don't wait
for her you go ask show her a little
respect
and then you take her out and you treat
her right how about that
don't make her cater to your whims right
treat her right
Treat Her Right treat her like see what
she is isn't this like a weird thing for
a political event a woman
a person of incredible significance
created in the image of God and you know
what you treat her right and then one
day you do her the honor and show her
the respect of asking her to marry you
yeah and then you go get married
uh dating advice with Josh Hawley
America Fest taking a very weird turn
there were like in-cell Vibes around the
entire thing then out came Dennis Prager
and he said sex is terrific okay thanks
Dennis
the greatest need in life after food and
shelter is meaning it is even when sex
and sex is terrific just for the record
right and they're a good blacks and bad
blacks did you guys know that there are
good blacks and bad blacks there are
even bad lesbians there are good women
and bad women there are good men and bad
men there are good whites and bad whites
we don't give a damn about whether
you're white we don't give a damn
whether you're black
just like you want you you brush away
your bad breath and you shower away your
bad odor you should brush away your bad
mood you owe it to everyone in your life
men can be lesbians are you out of your
mind yes they are we are living in the
age of chaos and you know the greatest
all right so there's Dennis Prager very
very messed up video
um it's it's just weird because so much
of the stuff they talk about is
meaningless like it helps no one achieve
anything or solve any problem it's
totally disconnected from The Real World
and then a guy named Benny Johnson got a
standing ovation for yelling fauci for
prison this is the this is the level of
what they have going on solving the real
problems of the world as you can see oh
Dr fauci's resigning how you like that
this is what my boy had to say about Dr
fauci just in time for Christmas
sick of seeing him I know he says he's
going to retire someone needs to grab
the
ground
who wants to see that elephant
ladies and gentlemen my pronouns are
prosecuted
come on
oh my goodness
um that's America Fest so if you were
hoping to learn what is their
legislative agenda for these two years
that they will be controlling the house
you didn't get it if you were hoping to
figure out what is the moral framework
within which they believe government
should I can't even say it seriously you
go government should operate you didn't
get that you got fire fouchy jail fouchy
prosecute fouchie fauci retire and you
got my pronouns are i1 and my pronouns
are prosecute fauci that's basically
America Fest that's what we got but
these events bring people together they
do them for a reason they do them for a
reason and the left should figure it out